hello welcome to the shore method my
name is Sean MacInnis and I'm Sean
mcinnes but who's the hell you drive
never heard of it never heard him
Shaun's away doing he's actually funnily
enough he is on an island he has a
tropical island enjoying him I would
it's a Mediterranean island let's not go
to full Travis true yeah that's true we
are gonna be on the tropical island yes
we are where myself and the Chris waters
here are going to play yeah i'm going to
guess 2004 classic you just hold that
one out of the arrow go on show us like
a little voice offset thanks booty
though FarCry the via titular
first-person shooter from Crytek yeah
this game is a really dumb intro hot
gamer babes just taking off
wait okay wait yep crap yep what what is
happening why are there blood molecules
that was lava wait oh man this is trippy
oh he's falling into lava no he's not
it's okay he's swimming and now he's a
Martin Sheen Charlie Sheen do you know
what is the best way to get someone to
trust you say I could have totally
messed with you already but i did in
Psalm trustworthy is there really a
stealth ometer yeah then the bottom left
are the piggies if I unleash the piggies
maybe that'll distract them go my piggy
friends before they murder you get out
don't make me stop one of you get it oh
[ __ ] alright man get out or you're gonna
be like your buddy well you're failing
right now that pig is you're not gaining
its trust you need to use trust words
and push it also that is a terrible pig
face oh my god it looks horrible and
going she's really gonna shove the pig
out the door get out go this game was
made in Russia Dino warthogs look like
did I was shoving it out of the door
with your abs get it this guy looks like
he is at he is mid-coitus perhaps
perhaps he is standing in his ovaries he
said he's a doggy style action figure
that someone knocked over you're
disgusting oh no oh oh oh it's sausage
this game has just got sex on the brain
check out this underwater area wow so
much shoot me you're being eaten by a
[ __ ] is going on why are you screaming
is he's a terrified of water his name oh
yeah oh god yeah I think yeah here we go
now you're really oh wow yeah lift the
leg up and is X come on get out of my
tower can you hope that's not the guy
you just resurrected today I want to
soon I want to shoot i don't i J hotties
are you
oh [ __ ] around I'm oh [ __ ] you know what
keeps happening stop screaming why keeps
happening as I keep running into the
water when I have no stamina cuz that's
awesome I air meter so you just run in
and you're just like limply drowning yes
your arms don't work anymore can't
breathe so buddy scream buddy Kishore
can make a real hearty scream underwater
the first time I got this guy it was
super also is it so much fun look at
this [ __ ] what the [ __ ] happened there I
just exploded and was out of the car get
it there must be a couple of dozen gas
between where they blew up that boat in
here step step step step step oh i
forgot i could throw rocks i'm trying to
stone as that stab stab stab okay yeah
said throw a rock at his face throw
rocks in your face in your dotage she's
gonna fill this room up full of rocks
all right this guy Katie failed [ __ ]
military school the key is to walk
backwards is it come yeah damn it I'm
stuck in this yeah then we gotta go do
the visor again you know how I feel
about the water nope now I didn't just
one of those human face paintings here
oh [ __ ] that's gonna conduit auto stab
stab stab stab turn off false alarm no
one's here everything's cool here we
just had to shoot off some guns and then
all be dead Oh she'll shoot me in the
ass oh great it's saved the game there
are you kidding me he's learning I'm
stuck on the door I'm stuck on the door
and I'm just three people shooting me
yes you're free ah [ __ ] come on man
how did you free yourself oh damn it is
right
now we're talking yeah I helped instant
death cuz you're a guy on the Left he's
like over there it's hard to hit him
this is this is terrible all right damn
it all on you like your cart the carnage
was you not them oh oh no now you're
just worried all right I'll disoriented
go gonna drive just a post-traumatic
stress okay God ya threw a grenade at me
for the second time I was underwater
it's a baby know if that was your
trigger what's he just crab walk out of
there do you see that a shot it's hard
to see wow it's just really going jesus
christ almighty walking away Fred and I
can't have a real light jog what's a
flume what the [ __ ] was that do you guys
but don't see some physics no oops oops
well there were some physics I was sure
you can hold on to that rope I don't
know where anyone else says I'm
terrified peekaboo you for [ __ ] day
what does happen all right you got is
that boat here oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] stop
[ __ ] this is supposed to be the show
method not torture chamber what the hell
is going on here oh you got him did he
die yup there he goes yeah that's right
some [ __ ] more for the road or watery
grave that was not a request oh yeah oh
my god I I want to do that when I died I
was sick you like a helicopter around
the room that was the best death rattle
I've ever seen I don't play this game
anymore can you jump off the can you do
it load it and jump off I'm sure bolt
towards the edge you know what I bet
I'll faileth out as well let's try it
just jump just bolt dive into the deep
blue sea and swim away
yep you are feeling at that thanks none
up you're not even better man woke up
the ladder I can't walk up the ladder
it's on my fault Danny good tries you
know my shorts you made it past them
tough parts you got to show off your
mighty calves at the end of the stream
uh decent work filling in for Shawn I
appreciate that thanks Sean yeah no
problem Shawn aha folks this just to
clarify for a couple of you this was the
Sean methods slot you can see look it's
right here mmm tomorrow is random
encounter with this guy I don't know
it's gonna be you know why there was
some way to know what it was gonna be
either way yeah follow Danny on Twitter
maybe he'll say something about it or
just tune in tomorrow at 11am Pacific of
course also stick around today on
gamespot we got a ton of news about
sony's recently announced vr headset the
Morpheus and tonight the IGF and GDC
Awards yes it's we're gonna be
televising them here on gamespot it's
like a real fun award ceremony for
awesome games it's great watch it I've
watched that stream for like seven years
and this year I got to go and I can't
wait I'm in the jury it's great it I
don't have to watch it at 2am in my
house anymore trying to stay awake but
you might if you live in the UK I'm
sorry but Daniel be there alright folks
thanks for watching we'll see you uh let
me see you happy hump day bye bye
Oh